[Musique]
je vois bien une bouteille ou bonjour
mathieu sarrat bonjour bonjour ça va
[Musique]
mais tu ton corps tu restes avec moi
aujourd'hui je peux pas mon cas
posséder
[Musique]
tout le dossier constitué de photos plus
ou moins grossier
on prend date pourquoi contre mathieu
qu'est ce qu'il leur a fait j'aimerais
avoir des nouvelles de ma fille et aussi
je veux voir
tu vas pas sa nature moi qui décide d'un
papa diouf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
keystone xl à istres
[Musique]
et france exit la personne aux savoirs
et les russes ni la presse personne
n'écoute pas moi j'étais petit ça c'est
pas mal
derrag l'heure n'est pas aux hobbies non
je ne fais pas mettre en péril nos
relations avec la russie pour groupe aux
yeux hors de question d'approuver une
opération clandestine pour faire quitter
le territoire
la seule solution c'est de vous rendre
de temps et telus
mais je suis innocent wendel